[Music]
oh my God what are they gonna say is it
a Lie Is it true Kyle Richards and
Mauricio umanski are standing United
amid all of the separation rumors
Mauricio shared photos with Kyle and his
family on Instagram celebrating the 4th
of July together now this comes after
many eagle-eyed fans noticed that Kyle
and country singer Morgan Wade have
gotten extremely close with many
pointing out that they have the exact
same heart tattoo and have been wearing
matching silver rings on their left-hand
ring fingers Kyle has yet to address the
speculation around her friendship with
Morgan it sounds so easy on paper
sit down and talk about it but
as history goes with us
that hasn't really worked foreign
[Music]
looks like Avril Lavigne and Tyga have
reignited their Romance the pair
responded at nobu's Fourth of July party
together and she appeared in his latest
tech talk promoting his new single Bops
going brazy
plus they were also spotted hanging out
together of the weekend in Las Vegas
last month it was reported that the two
called things off after three and a half
months of dating
[Music]
cardi B and her husband offset are
enjoying Paris fashion week together the
two were posing for photos all glammed
up for the Balenciaga show this comes
after offset accused cardi of cheating
on him last week in a since deleted
Instagram story cardi denied allegations
and announced shisani do not disturb
type of Summer
[Music]